bueno la enfermedad que padece el primer
ministro como has dicho es la misma que
le obligó a dejar el cargo en el año
2007 se trata de colitis crónica
ulcerosa es una enfermedad que en
realidad no tiene cura pero que puede
mejorar mucho con un tratamiento
adecuado es una enfermedad que en
realidad si no se trata adecuadamente
puede por ejemplo generar el cáncer de
colon de ahí que me haya explicado que
obviamente no se siente capaz ahora
mismo de gobernar el país en cuanto a lo
esperado de su renuncia bueno se rumoreó
se empezó a rumorar ya la semana pasada
después de que acudiera a una clínica y
estuviera ahí varias horas para
realizarse muchísimas pruebas médicas
esta semana regresó otra vez a esa misma
clínica a realizarse otra serie de
pruebas durante durante varias horas y
en ese punto ya la comunidad
periodística sospechaba que para finales
de esta semana probablemente el primer
ministro iba cómo calmar la empresa para
anunciar su renuncia
todo el proceso recordaba mucho a lo
sucedido ya en 2007 si ahora andrés
quien podría ser el sucesor de ave y
cómo sería el proceso de elección
pues es una muy buena pregunta en la ley
de marca
el primer ministro debe ser el
presidente del partido político más
votado en las últimas elecciones
nacionales en este caso se trata del
conservador partido liberal demócrata de
simpson al que aún no ha determinado qué
sistema va a elegir para pitar quién va
a ser su nuevo presidente a falta de
aclarar esto una vez que el partido pues
que convoque el proceso por el cual va a
elegir a su nuevo máximo mandatario este
presidente del partido liberaldemócrata
debe someterse a una votación en la
dieta en el parlamento japonés donde
obviamente el partido liberaldemócrata
tiene mayoría así que se espera y
obviamente salga refrendado como primer
ministro entre los candidatos que suenan
con más fuerza por ejemplo el ministro
de defensa caro cono que es un político
muy popular y también un ex canciller al
igual que canaco no conocía y fue mixto
efectores pero hay otro ministro de
exteriores yo quisiera y ha anunciado su
intención de ser sucesor de abel andrés
muy brevemente tras el anuncio el nikkei
japonés perdió un 1.4 por ciento como
fue
a la economía de japón y le pregunto si
también podemos esperar más cierres a la
baja en los próximos días
referencia al cni que iba subiendo toda
la jornada de hoy hasta que se ha
conocido se ha adelantado la noticia de
hecho el acabado cayendo un 1,4 por
ciento se puede tal vez esperar algunas
caídas en los próximos días sobre todo
dependiendo de cómo va a ir ese proceso
que hemos mencionado para la selección
de un nuevo presidente del partido
liberaldemócrata que luego sea candidato
a primer ministro en función de quien
sea esa persona y de cómo de ágil dice
ese proceso que se calcula que pueda
tardar un par de semanas como sucedió ya
en 2007